die unabhängigen experten suchen in
erster linie was ist die diagnose ist es
eine vergiftung welches gift war es also
da wird auf jeden fall hier wird was
getan
im gegensatz zu russland wo er mehr oder
weniger versucht wird das ganze so ein
bisschen unter den tisch zu kehren
ganz genau also dabei die wird erst mal
behandelt damit damit er wieder gesund
wird steht ja auch noch überhaupt nicht
fest welche langzeitfolgen diese
vergiftung haben kann
da wollen die ist ja nicht einfach so
ins koma gefallen sondern dass es war
ein ziemlich ernsthafte anschlag auf
sein leben und ja zum zweiten ist es
natürlich die frage welches gift wurde
eingesetzt wird verfügt über solche
giftstoffe und wer kann sie dann
eventuell eingesetzt haben und hier in
deutschland können ärzte ganz frei den
patienten untersuchen und natürlich auch
ganz frei über ihre erkenntnisse mit
öffentlichkeit kommunizieren beides ist
in russland nicht möglich wir würden die
russische regierung darauf reagieren
wenn jetzt in deutschland raus genialer
wurde vergiftet
also es ist gar keine große große sache
für russland wenn man sich mal die
innen- und außenpolitische bilanz putins
der letzten jahre anschaut die haben so
viel gemacht
der kreml hat so viel unheil angerichtet
da wurden so viele oppositionelle
vergiftet umgebracht ins exil geschickt
alles mögliche und es gab keine es gibt
keine sanktionen
die haben eigentlich nicht viel zu
befürchten
man wird alles abstreiten wenn die wenn
der kreml 1 kann dann propaganda im
internet im russischen internet werden
schon diverse spins gesetzt also da wird
behauptet dass navalny einfach nur sehr
viel getrunken hat am vorabend und
deswegen ein schwächeanfall hatte also
ich bin mir sicher wir werden dann noch
vieles aus russland hören was nicht der
wahrheit entspricht und was einfach nur
die version bestärken soll das ist
natürlich keine vergiftung gab und dass
sich eventuell die deutschen behörden
einfach nur irgendetwas ausdenken werden
was mit der realität nichts zu tun hatte
das ist ja jetzt die aktuelle news dass
er wahrscheinlich auslegen darf vor
einigen stunden war das ganze noch
überhaupt nicht klar
wir haben ein video von der frau vorbei
nämlich polyana vagni und sie hat sich
vor einigen stunden an die presse
gewendet beziehungsweise versucht sich
hier noch wie wir auf dem video sehen zu
ihrem mann zu kommen
wir sehen sie wird praktisch ab gewesen
darf wie gesagt nicht zu ihrem mann und
wurde nach draußen auf der wiesn
[Musik]
ausklang krankenhaus mit der ehefrau
eines koma
er ist wahnsinnig starke frau die sofort
zu ihrem mann nach hause geflogen ist
ins krankenhaus gekommen ist und wurde
erst lange nicht auf die intensivstation
gelassen dann doch dann heute wieder
wieder nicht es gab nämlich besuch von
den deutschen ärzten die konnten sich
ein bild von der lage machen die konten
zu neuwahlen gegeben und die ehefrau
wollte natürlich mit kommen und wollte
zum ersten mal mit diesen ausländischen
experten sprechen und da wurde sie nicht
vorgelassen
da gab es irgendwelche bilder bulligen
sicherheitsmänner die sie weggestoßen
haben die sie nicht durchgelassen haben
die deutschen erst wurden dann über
einen hinterausgang in ein auto gebracht
und vom krankenhaus gelände gefahren
also das regime versucht einfach nur die
frau zu drangsalieren wo es geht
nun ja wir können jetzt hoffen dass es
dass es doch geklappt hat die frau ist
wirklich bis ans äußerste gegangen sie
hat heute ein forderungs brief einen
offenen brief an putin geschrieben das
muss man sich mal vorstellen dass sie
schreibt einen offenen brief an den
erzfeind ihres mannes und man muss es so
hart sagen auch an den mutmaßlichen
drahtzieher und an den wahrscheinlichen
wahrscheinlichsten drahtzieher dieser
ganzen dieses ganzen anschlags an
wladimir putin und verlangt von ihm dass
ihr mann endlich nach deutschland
gelassen wird wenn das jetzt doch darf
wenn er doch nach deutschland kommen
kann dann hat sich das hoffentlich alles
gelohnt
eine abschließende frage
die frau hat sehr gekämpft für ihren
mann und er hat auch zwei kinder leben
die drei also geht der rest der familie
leben die genauso gefährlich wie alexei
navalny selbst die gefährdungslage von
alexei navalny ist seit jahren etwas für
über ganz viel spekuliert wird in
russland
das ist die frage die im journalisten
interviews am häufigsten stellen
ferner baldi warum leben sie eigentlich
überhaupt noch er ist der prominenteste
kritiker das des präsidenten
ich durfte herne wahlen die 2018 auch
interview ich habe eben auch diese frage
gestellt und da konnte sich auch keinen
reim darauf bilden man kann auf jeden
fall sagen dass es hier sich hier beim
sehr starke menschen eine sehr starke
familie handelt ich weiß nicht ob man
sich daran gewöhnen kann aber die kinder
sind natürlich mit der angst
aufgewachsen dass ihrem vater etwas
zustoßen kann und dem vater ist auch
mehrfach schon etwas zugestoßen
er war mehrfach im gefängnis einmal
wurde mit einem gewissen chemischen
farbstoff wurde er im gesicht beworfen
ist fast erblindet also das passiert
regelmäßig und ich glaube man kann keine
kann die sicherheit erwarten in diesem
land in russland wenn man sich so in der
opposition engagiert wie navalny aber
ich glaube er ist einfach optimist und
die familie auch umso bewundernswerter
dass er immer noch für diese sache
kämpft philipp jakob vielen vielen dank
dass uns all die fragen beantworten